joe biden is so
there for it he is so on the mark he is
like if called upon he will spring to
his feet he will answer the call this is
the inflection point we have to prevent
the catastrophe of a world boiling
itself to death joe biden fell asleep
like actually fell asleep in the middle
of one of these climate change
conferences
you can see him there he is eyes start
to close
and joe biden is gone he is now sleeping
in the middle of this conference
there he is he's clearly out he's
clearly out cold
like my baby in the back seat of the car
in a long drive joe biden is gone in
fact joe biden had to be woken up by an
aide to clap at the end of the speech i
am not kidding you that is a thing that
actually happened the the face of a
decaying west is joe biden
a career politician who's never done a
productive thing in his entire life
pledging to destroy
the fundamental institutions of the west
ranging from family to free markets